welcome ben and aaron napier
what's up hey drew i have been like your
biggest fan
since my whole life basically so this is
a really big moment for me
you're uh
you're kind of rocking the hair i have
to say
yeah and i put it very short when i went
to college
which is when i noticed her yes ben
really loved my short hair and that's
why he noticed me and i was just trying
to be drew barrymore
so anyway also our three-year-old helen
is obsessed with e.t
very exciting to helen
yeah you're you're a part of our life
every day does she plan to marry
elliot when she grows up yeah that's
weird yeah i had a crush on him too but
he was like my brother and that was just
weird
um and i mean it's so funny that you
would say i'm in your home because
that is what you guys you know the word
home
is in your show title and there's so
much meaning
behind the word home yeah it's a it's an
incredible thing and it's an incredible
honor that we get to
help so many people you know find their
first home
find a transitional home find their
you know their their livestock their
forever and
we we love what we get to do we do and
we are extreme
oh i'm more extreme than i'm an extreme
homebody home is everything
and that's the thing when i'm designing
a home on hometown i'm always thinking
if i were the person who lived here what
would make me long
for it when i'm away from it and that
like that is what home is it's not how
perfect and
pretty and pinterest worthy your house
is it's so much more than that
everything you said just it totally
encapsulates why i think you guys are so
successful
and so i think your philosophy is what
connects with people and makes you
uh you know the success that you are and
connect to people
the way you do because if you go into
their home with that intention
that translates that transfers i hope so
that's the only way i know how to do
this and it's you know it's there are
things like you know pretty pain colors
and pretty
you know sofas and things and you know
we can
we can help you find that that's that's
the easy part of it the hard part of our
job is
getting to know the homeowners and then
figuring out okay
what makes this person tick what makes
them want to be
you know at home what what can we do to
this house yes we're going to make it
beautiful but
we want it to be theirs personal
personal personal over pretty
that's always our concern now you guys
met
in college right and
you were in you were getting a degree in
fine arts erin
and ben you were getting a degree in
history
how did that affect like your design
and how what's the rear view mirror of
like your intention of what you wanted
to learn in college and how it applies
to this
amazing life you're living now i think
so like
for me it's easy to point out like i
studied history and i love the history
of these houses
i love you know researching it and
getting to know it and learning
how how craftspeople did things you know
100 years ago 150 years ago and
you know trying to implement that into
what we do i think you have a real
reverence for what
the house was yes and how it became that
and how we can maintain the heart and
soul
of what it was original yeah and then
also but also like
who lived there and like what what their
life was like and how they affected this
you know incredible town that we get to
live in
but then from your point of view we've
all
said that aaron so aaron used to have a
stationary company and it was
internationally successful she sold
stationery all over the world and it was
incredible
and she's always said that designing
wedding stationery is the same thing as
designing somebody's house
you just have to figure out yeah you're
just taking people's hearts
you're taking their personalities their
past
and their love and you're putting it
into something visual
it's the exact same thing either way
yeah
do you have like little like things that
you're just like these are
non-negotiables these are rules we have
like i always want to do
curtains at least a foot out from either
side of the window so that the fabric
doesn't cover
the windows like when you mount do you
have like
little pet peeves and things you must do
i have a hang up about baseboards
[Music]
and i think that honestly comes from
like in art school when you mad a piece
of art you have
more space at the bottom like the bottom
of a mat is usually one inch taller than
the top but visually
it looks equal anyway baseboards just
make a room look balanced to me and you
need a big one
i think that that's our big thing like
as designers
i consider myself to be a furniture
designer but it's
for us it's about balance so like if
you're building if you walk into a room
and you see a table
and it's got big thick chunky legs
and then a really thin top it doesn't
look right it's like something
about it just hurts me a little bit
yes i i i feel like i'm at the front row
of my favorite themes of life which is
design
you